and journeys mouth reaction our two
Republican lawmakers congresswoman
Marsha Blackburn and Congressman Peter
Roskam thank you both for being with us
on the busy news thank you very much
thank you okay so I want to begin with
you and congresswoman Blackburn how big
of a victory do you think this is going
to be for president Trump's agenda this
is something he promised and he heavily
campaigned on something that he needs to
get a win on the board also going to be
pivotal for 2018 for midterm elections
it is a big win Kimberly because this is
the type win that everybody is going to
see the results and the benefits of
almost immediately after the first of
the year because these kick in January 1
so employees can go set they're
withholding they'll be able to take more
money home in that paycheck beginning in
January there also for our small
business owners who are going to be
looking at their tax schedules and
saying all right we pay quarterly and
think about Main Street America all
those shops that line the streets
they're going to be able to reset
because of the lower business rate that
applies to all of these small businesses
okay and congressman Roskam now what do
you think about this it seems to me that
they've been able to work very well I
mean particularly we see that President
Trump has worked well with a number of
constituents that perhaps haven't
supported in the past but also worked
very closely with Paul Ryan to get this
through look it's a very big
insignificant day all the way around I
think in part we've been shaped by the
struggles on the health care debate and
it was a very difficult time to go
through and incredibly disappointing I
think people on Capitol Hill Republicans
on Capitol Hill recognized that and said
let's not repeat that and there's an
interesting dynamic too in that there's
really no defender of the status quo as
it relates to our tax code today the tax
codes a disaster 70,000 pages and it's
holding us back and what we were able to
do in the course of this process is
bring a wide range of opinions together
around this idea of doing two things
number one offering real tax relief up
and down the spectrum and primarily
towards folks in the middle
come and number two giving businesses
tax relief as Marsha just said to create
a different business environment much
more forward-leaning
much more investment oriented and much
more expansive and that is something
that I think most folks are really
pleased about ok so where do we go from
here congressman Blackburn and in terms
up like the president trying to use this
maybe for other legislation going
forward as sort of a you know a
framework for support to get people on
board to put some of the legislation
forward that he needs because there was
a struggle
you know with trying to repeal and
replace Obamacare but this seems to have
gone much more smoothly it has gone much
more smoothly and we fully anticipate
that you'll see health care come back in
the spring but you think about it like
this Kimberly we have addressed
regulations the president has been doing
a great job of working with us a lot of
that has come off the books we've been
able to address taxation and we know
that those two together will lead to job
creation now that means we need to pivot
to infrastructure and we need to begin
to look at the out-of-control spending
what is happening with all of the
entitlements where you see that growth
sending Medicaid back to the states so
we can pivot work on infrastructure work
on getting the spending under control
2018 is going to be a fantastic year
it's going to be a year of
accomplishment and I look forward to it
alright and congressman Roskam you know
if in particular Chicago people could
use and you know some support and
Illinois there what do you make of it
yeah that's for sure so the Illinois
General Assembly in July of this year
jammed through a massive income tax hike
and it really hit folks in the middle
income and it hit folks up and down the
spectrum this is welcome relief for my
constituents in this in suburban Chicago
and all throughout Illinois and states
like Illinois that are positioned
differently than states like Tennessee
that are doing better because of better
tax policy are getting welcomed relief
under this bill I'm really proud to be a
part of it okay well we're waiting this
as you see Senate vote on the tax reform
bill we want to thank you both for your
time tonight
congresswoman Blackburn and Congress
rasca